[Music]
we do have breaking developments out of
the deep state investigation tonight the
attorney general bill barr
revealed today that he has appointed
john durham special counsel to
investigate the origins
of the russia hoax which will allow the
investigation to continue
joining us now with reaction author of
the new book fire brand florida
congressman matt gates fox news legal
analyst greg jarrett good to see you
both greg
you wrote two number one bestsellers on
this
from my perspective john durham has had
more than enough information
uh about russian disinformation dossier
uh premeditated fraud on a fisa court
and he's had forever to do it why hasn't
he gotten the job done
well according to the attorney general
he needs more time kovid
interfered with the legal process but
this was a shrewd and smart move by bill
barr he's essentially made john durham
elliot ness he's untouchable giving him
elevated status as special counsel
remember
the ag is gone when a new administration
comes in and so are the 93 u.s
attorneys and durham is one of those but
now
he can continue his investigation until
its conclusion
unimpeded you know it's difficult for a
new president to fire a special counsel
or the attorney general remember when
trump just
talked about firing
bob mueller democrats in the media
accused him of obstruction of justice
but the second important thing is
durham in addition to issuing
indictments
uh can now write a report to provide a
full accounting of the corrupt acts the
abuse of power by people like
james comey andrew mccabe peter strzok
and others i would include rod
rosenstein
maybe even sally yates in that yates is
now effectively
off the table i think as the next
attorney general in a
biden administration assuming the
electoral college
chooses him you know there's a fake news
cnn story tonight that
has been debunked by a doj official uh
about the trump administration official
and money for pardons they said
no no government official was or is
currently a subject of any target of any
investigation
disclosed uh matt gates uh
i read the new york times op-ed by
andrew weissman
three years he was robert mueller's
pitbull
didn't get the result he wanted uh now
he's saying that if biden becomes
president
has an ag he wants trump elect uh
investigated in perpetuity uh you had
said it first that i agree with you
if if this is the threat that they're
going to make to a
guy leaving office perhaps one day
my question is why wouldn't he just
pardon himself and his family
on the way out the door because i think
he would be right to do so because these
people are nuts
the president should pardon himself his
family his administration officials and
any of his supporters who've been
targeted look this
department of justice and fbi targeted
president trump
and wanted to accuse him of crimes when
he was the incoming president what do
you think that they're going to do if
they think he's the outgoing president
i think the durham announcement is
really a letdown
essentially we're ending where they
started they started by appointing
a special counsel and we may be ending
by appointing a special counsel
that'll be a let down to a lot of
americans who've seen the doj become
politicized